good morning and welcome to bio
conference life sciences conference 2012
my name is Catherine Borden I'm a
professor at University of Montreal and
today I'm going to be speaking about
when my favorite oncogene the eukaryotic
initiation factor 4e but before I get
started the organizers asked me to make
two announcements the first is that as
your questions come to mind please
submit your questions for the while I'm
speaking so that I can address them all
at the end of the presentation without
having a delay in waiting for questions
if I can address something while I'm
talking i will but we'll see how that
goes the second message is that
attendees can earn free siiii credits
accredited by the asp LS paste process
you can click on the file conference
live.com website homepage and click on
the cee credit link to find a listing of
my presentation click on that link and
you will be connected to an AFC LS web
site where the presentation can get
evaluated and you will receive your
credit te credit and a certificate so
not to get on to the presentation so
today I'm going to talk about the
eukaryotic initiation factor eif4e which
I'm going to just nickname for you
throughout the talk my talk is divided
roughly into two parts first aside from
giving you an introduction into this
oncogene and explaining it to overall
relevance to cancer I'm also going to
explain some molecular biological
mechanisms of how 4e can automatically
transform cells and then the rest of the
talk will be devoted to our finding that
eif where you can be target in the
clinic so give me some background on
that and also showing you at the end our
clinical data
so first of all we like to just explain
to you why anyone would be interested in
studying or targeting eif4e well first
of all its overexpression can lead to
transformation in cell culture and
animal models and rescue cells from a
wide variety of apathetic stimuli in
factoria is elevated in an estimated
thirty percent of cancers and
overexpression is normally linked to
poor prognosis for y over expressing
cells appear to develop an oncogene
dependency or addiction and so this
provides us with therapeutic window and
down here is just a little bluer but for
anybody who's perhaps not familiar with
the idea of oncogene addiction but what
in essence it means is that the cells
that are overexpressing for a grow more
dependent on them and that's targeting
for you in these cells is these cells
are more responsive to targeting for e
than normal cells and obviously this is
clinically relevant as you'll see later
on so this is just a very brief list of
the cancers that 40 is known to be
elevated in and I just like to state
that in some cancers such as head and
neck cancers eif4e elevations being
associated with with above ninety eight
percent of these cancers in other
characters such as acute myeloid
leukemia for your over expression is
only known to be elevated in the m4m
five subtypes this is a subtype that
we'll be discussing at length later and
in other cancers for instance breast
cancer for is elevated and approximately
fifty percent so we have quite a wide
variety of the presence of for a
contributing mainly or partly to certain
subsets of these catchers as well as
many others so for is upregulated in all
of these cancers and so how does four
become elevated and I don't really have
time to talk about it in detail today
but just to give you some ideas corey is
actually elevated at most
levels so it's our innate stability can
be increased by Hur which is an RNA
stability factor and we see this and had
a net counters for instance in breast
cancers and also had a net conscious for
a elevation of being associated with
gene amplification and finally we have
evidence that the transcription of
boria's also increased and in some
cancers we have evidence that multiple
event it can be happening at the same
time all leading to the eventual
elevation of four E and i should say for
instance an m4 and m5 subtypes of cancer
that we see upwards of three to eight
even up to 10-fold elevation in the
patient's elevation is quite substantial
so to the next slide I'll just show you
what is for you do and so for each
function eyes divided in the slide to
being we're in the cytoplasmic or
nuclear compartments and in the
cytoplasm for a function is extremely
well-defined most of you will be very
very familiar with forties critical and
central role in translation of mrna into
protein which is obviously a critical
step in gene expression and so we'll
just go through the cytoplasmic side
first to give you a sort of a molecular
understanding of how these things are
working here this is a crystal structure
originally solved by burly blabberwort a
true diono paper in the 90s where you
see the 4e protein binding a critical
factor for this talk and for for a
function which is the methyl 7 guanidine
cat-boy team which is found on the five
prime end of all nuclear encoded mrna
and it's this moiety that is how 4e can
recognize RNA and a variety through
through it
cat what we call it at binding pocket
because we nicknamed the methamphetamine
cap or tap as for this and now the
dorsal surface of for a shown here much
of the translation machinery such a word
for G and the pie binding protein etc
will find to engage allow the eventual
engagement of the ribosome and
translation initiation now it turns out
that four-year overexpression does not
elevate the expression of all
transcripts equally well for instance
rnase would have complex five prime utr
s which typically are very long and
gc-rich are much more sensitive to the
levels of 4e for instance many years ago
now people over express for ian cells
and look at 35 s in defying any
corporation and do not seek global
increases in translation but rather
specific target seem to be much more
sensitive to its elevation and for
instance some of these would include
orison decarboxylase vascular
endothelial growth factor and many other
proteins and these proteins tend to be
involved in proliferation and apathetic
rescue thus contributing to the
oncogenic trend of academic
transformation activities of 4e because
as we know from animal models
overexpression of 4e leads to a wide
variety of histologically distinct
cancers as well as for overexpression
reading to to transformation in cell
type as i said at the very beginning of
this talk now the for you cytoplasmic
function is extremely well understood it
has a set of inhibitors and also
positive regulators and we were also
very curious though about the
substantial portion of nuclear 4e where
in some cells up to sixty eight percent
of 40 can be nuclear and as i'll show
you later on the the localization of 4e
can be quite context-dependent now in
this year for e we can see that
you must find this pipeline tap on the
RNA you know in order for RNAs to be
preferentially exported from the nucleus
to the cytoplasm and this allows their
increased availability to the
translation machinery without
necessarily increasing their
translational efficiency which is what
we define here at an increased
translation is increased palma loading
whereas here we define the effect on
gene expression as an increase in the
target transfer transcript localization
in the cytoplasm permitting increased
engagement of the polyfoam so again
there's nuclear specific factors that
can inhibit this such as pml ring and
the rnase that are being transported in
this way require not only a five prime
method lunging tap but also specific
approximately 50 nucleotide element we
call the eif4e sensitivity element or 40
for short and rnase which contained a
secondary structure elements shown here
have their RNA export promoted a pot
pourri overexpression in fact in fact
the addition of 42 lat said and other
chimeric reporters allows the increased
export of these RNA to the cytoplasm
these RNAs approximately 700 to date as
our estimation includes many cyclin such
as cyclin d1 and also targets such as
ODC which are also target for the
translation machinery that jet for
instance is only a target of the
translation machinery and not an export
target so we can have differential
effects on gene expression depending
whether or not the four years mainly
nuclear or maybe cytoplasmic or equally
distributed but together these functions
clearly drive proliferation and
apoptotic rescue at the cell biological
level which can ultimately contribute to
oncogenic transformation and I should
say that many of the genes as I said
already were involved in proliferation
and so 40 coordinate regulate
transcription involved in same
biochemical pathways and as I said
before we have to
remember this for later on the top that
this is all reliance on the top binding
activity which allows us something to
target
for for the next slide is showing you
just evidence that for you can actually
regulates the tRNA export process and
also very important finding in terms of
understanding RNA export of specific our
nation the nucleus is that for you only
associate with the subset of rnase in
the nucleus and this is completely
different to the cytoplasm we're 40
interacts with all rnase observed so
what you're seeing here is either IP of
eif4e or the IgG control looking at
cyclin d1 or sth RNA so we're looking at
transcript IP and if we just do an IP we
see a substantial enrichment of cyclin
d1 relative to get eh if we compete for
the cap with the Caprican compete off
this interaction showing its cap
dependent but if we use guanidine as our
negative control which can't bind 40 it
can't compete off and clearly our
control IPS look good now if we do for
you over expression and look at the
export of cyclin d1 RNA where we
fractionate the cells in from
cytoplasmic and the nuclear fractions
and analyze the RNA content of each
fraction using quantitative real-time
pcr again you can see that
overexpression of 4e reach the elevation
of the export of this transcript whereas
other transcripts which we published
extensively shown here like that th are
not affected so the fish specific and if
when you take the cap binding site
before you can't associate with RNA we
kill this activity now if we can also do
the converse experiments and do SI RNA
and what you're looking at here instead
of looking at the cytoplasmic to nuclear
ratio here we're looking at the nuclear
to cytoplasmic ratio so here we're
looking at nuclear retention of cyclin
d1 transcripts and if we SI 4e we have
increased nuclear retention of these
transcripts and if we use control
unrelated SI rnase or scrambled ironing
we don't have this effect so globally
for a vine specific rnase in the nucleus
and promotes their export so is this
clinically relevant of course you're
going to ask me and here we are going to
show you some data that indicates this
is now a particular interest is an m4 m5
AML and also to a lesser extent blast
crisis CML and the results on this slide
will reflect both of these populations
so if we isolate either cd34 positive
cells from normal individual so these
are primitive progenitor cells or the
same leukemic blast cells from an m4 AML
patients you can see that Forry is
clearly highly elevated but it's also
now jam packed into the nucleus just to
confirm that the protein levels are
elevated you can see here healthy
volunteers relative to the normal
patients relative to the AML or black
grace of CML patients and if we look at
cyclin d1 as a downstream effector of
ironing export you can see that this is
also elevated for downstream target I
should have sent now what we can also
see is that total levels of cyclin b1
RNA are not affected so this is a post
in this case cyclin d1 is not being
elevated transcriptionally and other
leukemias it may well be the case but
here we don't see back so we
fractionated ourselves and I should say
to the northern blot as this is last
panel here and if we fractionated cells
into nuclear and cytoplasmic fractions
we can see that in the AML patients or
the blush face 50ml patient that we have
substantial elevation of export relative
to the healthy volunteer no changing gap
th tRNA lighting serves as our
fractionation one of our fascination
controls where we've also published many
others here I've only shown you a bit of
a small handful of patient specimens but
we've analyzed over a hundred and
specimens to date and this is the
phenotype which gene in every single m4
m5 specimen that we've seen this also
indicates this increased nuclear export
that the highly enriched jam-packed for
a nuclear phenotype in the AML and four
subtypes is biologically relevant IED
cells are actively exporting their RNAs
and are doing it more shows than the
healthy volunteers so the obvious
question is how does for a dependent
already export work because clearly we
have already a very detailed
understanding of how are any translation
works in terms of forage role and
translation initiation and how does it
contribute to oncogenesis because as i
will show you it does contribute to
oncogenesis row that not only time for
m5 AML so you know in recent studies
that we've done we simply ask the
question how is poor II causing the
promotion of us already export what are
the actual mechanics that underlie this
and it turns out that this realized very
much on modifications for you can make
the nuclear pore complex or NPC what we
already knew previously and published it
published in 2009 is that Forry with the
for the RNA that we shown here so the
subsets of RNAs containing that special
three prime utr elements specifically
interact with something called the
leucine-rich protein and crim one which
is which is a nuclear export receptor
allows docking on to the nuclear pore
and permits export but understanding the
composition of the nuclear pore doesn't
a priority help us understand y 4 y over
expression actually elevates this
process and so here you can see many the
nuclear pore complexes are detailed and
we're not going to worry about the
specific details of this except with
regard to a handful of proteins so the
nuclear pore is made up of a nuclear
basket the central channel by which the
molecules can pasture to the site up
them and then these cytoplasmic Sybil's
which are very important to the story
I'm telling you each day and cytoplasmic
Sybil's are thought to be a site where
where cargos RNA containing or protein
containing our cargoes can bind you to
the main constituent of the Pharaohs
known as RAM pp2 are also known as not
358 and reform 358 and through GPS
activity of RAM vp2 allows release of
the cargoes allowing recycling of the
export factors and the freedom of the
cargo to go to wherever it needs to go
in the south apt and this case the RNA
to the translation machinery so our
studies actually show quite strikingly
these are all western blots that if we
overexpress 4e relish it's a vector that
we substantially reduce the levels of
the ram vp to protein and as I said ram
PP 2 is a major constituent of
cytoplasmic liberals and so we're likely
changing the overall structure of the
nuclear pore by for overexpression we
know that other factor here are not
changing your protein levels and so this
is not a global effect on the nuclear
pore but rather specific effect team to
be targeted in order for for e2 to
promote export and as you'll see later
to actually aid in promoting the
oncogenic transformation that we see we
also have some positive control here
where you see cyclin d1 tzemach are
already established for a target sapori
overexpression elevates them as it does
MVH one and we also found that other
cargo release factors for RNA export 31
and edx 9 are also elevated by four E
and finally what what's very comforting
and interesting to us is the elevation
of this factor Randy t1r a BP one the
other major protein that helps the
release of these these factors but its
soluble rad vp 2 is 30 58 kill dalton
protein that makes
cosmic several Ramsey t1 is a 23 filled
out and protein that that is soluble and
we think as you'll see later is actually
speeding up cargo release and recycling
of components and this is how for your
overexpression promotes the export of it
rnas now but we overexpressed here but
in this column here we use SI for e and
we get the expected converse effect
where we highly elevate randy picchu as
you can see here and also as you can see
the positive targets of for you DD x 19
31 and randy p2 are all down down
regulated consistent with what they're
up regulation upon overexpression and
finally if we use a pharmacological
inhibitor of 40 called ribavirin to
competitive inhibitor of the cap and
also discussed at length later we also
see the expected decrease in our
positive targets but also an increase in
ram BP too so things that inhibit for a
transfer media transformation seem to
elevate ram vp 2 and 4 e seems to want
to lower around vp 2 and dutch reduce
the cytoplasmic several in order to
promote both its export and as you'll
see transformation activities so well
the obvious experiments to see if this
was a functionally important observation
because i'll showed you was a was
approaching over approaching expression
change was to overexpress ram BP to our
MVP to being 358 kilodaltons cannot
really be overexpressed by itself but we
took the zinc finger regions of ram be
Picchu which are known to buying cream 1
and be important for our export activity
and you can see here if we look at both
a black said which is not sensitive to
4e levels or of lack set for Z which is
now an export target ofori
overexpression of ram BP to drink
figured fingers causes a reduction
in the levels of lack set and
consistently if we look at the RNA
export we see here that in vectors with
high for e we have increased export of
lex at fourth years we'd expect and when
we overexpress reb db2 we not sat down
substantially and if we look at an
endogenous RNA see Mick we can see the
overexpression of the zinc-finger here
or here of RAM bb2 represses androgynous
RNA export targets as well black said by
itself total RNA is unaffected and also
ubiquitin a not an RNA export target
does not is not affected by any of the
things that we've done so this is
specific also you note that lack said
not being sensitive to 4e is not
particularly sensitive to overexpression
of ram PP 2 as well I don't have time to
show you but we've reached it recently
published that if we use another
constructs generated from Ram be p2
which cannot bind crim one does not
contain these things fingers there's no
effect on for a dependent RNA export so
this is specific to this region of ram
be p2 now does this have anything to do
with oncogenic transformation and that's
a very good question so Rabi picchu we
can see here we use a full-size
formation assay so we're looking at
their loss of contact inhibition and
fiberglass and as you if you have either
overexpression of 4e or of 4e + r MVP
choosing fingers you can see we have a
substantial reduction in full sign
number upon a living fingers really
supporting our idea that this RNA export
activity is contributing to the
oncogenic transformation
looking at wide variety and doggedness
are any targets and overexpressing for e
or mutant forms of for e to establish it
that we can make a link between
transformation RNA exports and
functionality of this so we looked at
two mutants in particular we looked at
the w 73a which is active in exports but
not in translation we've published that
previously and another mutant which is
active in translation but not export f53
a as you'll see here we determined we
started the studies only knowing that
this was deficient this is there was
sufficient good at translation and you
can see here that in all of the 40
sensitive rnase we look at the s 53 a
mutation is completely unable to to
promote the export of known targets or
the recently identified targets we see
here and furthermore f53 a this does not
cause suppression of my BB to as seen by
4 E or the export competent mutant w 73
a so we can make the link here that that
the ability to export is linked to the
ability to modulate round EP 2 levels
and furthermore I don't have time to
show you but if published in this recent
paper we can actually see when we do RNA
immunoprecipitations that well we
clearly have for e amir precipitating on
specific rnase and the nucleus as i
showed you earlier on in the top that s
53 a has no RNA binding activity in the
nucleus however NMR studies show that
the sp3 a mutant is still totally active
in cat binding and cytoplasmic RNA
immunoprecipitations show that SSD 3a
works as well as wild-type for RNA
immune or precipitation so clearly yes
53 a mutant represents a key tool that
we can use to try to understand what
factors in the nucleus for you must bind
in order to make the specific are
p now how is this relevant to the
oncogenic potential of 4e we're using
the same anchorage dependent foci
formation a state so looking at the loss
of contact inhibition here where you
have more blue clearly you have lots of
the oncogenic transformation and you can
see our point mutation f53 a completely
abrogate this and so this really
strongly suggests that the f50 create
mutants is it's going to be key if this
mutant as again as I said it's deficient
and export but previous studies by
several other labs have shown that extra
period active and translation and yet it
cannot transform self highlighting the
relevance of this RNA export activity
for e2 transformation at least in some
context so what's our summary model here
you're seeing the nucleus and cytoplasm
under normal conditions or the
conditions of 4e overexpression here
these dark purple lines are our MVP to
cytoplasmic Sybil's and what we can see
is as our cargoes go through they they
can get stuff either sequestered on
Randy Picchu and slower release a lot of
slowing down there their transport to
the cytoplasm and also potentially
flowing down the recycling of important
factors that are required for export
under the Fourier overexpression
condition short on this side what we can
see is we actually have reduced
cytoplasmic liberals as soon by reduced
gravity two and we actually have
elevated RAM ep.1 compensating for this
and the soluble factors from how
increases the rate of recycling and
cargo release thereby increasing this
process and obviously as we said the MTP
to several seem to be playing a very
important role in the oncogenic
transformation potential of for you as
well
so now that we've done in depth about
writers they're about four E and four HR
any export activity it's going to be
clinically relevant because we can see
that this is elevated in patients as i
already showed you an example or two of
earlier on and given that all of the
activities of for eating the nuclear and
cytoplasmic activity both are dependent
on the tap for tap binding activity we
were very much interested in seeking out
ways that we could inhibit this activity
potentially use this oncogene addiction
to to target cancer cells with over
expression for e and sparing normal
cells and potentially giving clinical
benefit so let me just summarize these
slides here so I'm going to summarize
the data we found to date and a series
of papers listed here and then I'll show
you some of the supporting data as well
as as the clinical trial data that we
have out of ribavirin monotherapy and
combination therapies in in AML patients
so today I'm going to show you evidence
that right very directly binds 4e the
Divine's for you in or out overlapping
with the cat binding site we know that
right ovarian inhibitory activity in
tissue culture you already saw some
evidence of that when we compared our SI
4h ribavirin experiments in the van BP
to day of a shop Robbie right ovarian
and for ii complexes are found in live
cells my River and inhibitory activity
in patients and also in primary
specimens what I don't have time to talk
to you about today but I would just like
to note now is that the loss of
ribavirin for interactions and cancer
and our patient capture child correlates
with the clinical resistance
so this is one of the evidences that
rather than directly binds 4e we simply
mix ribavirin with with guanidine or in
this case plunging triphosphate as a
negative control what I think
triphosphate is no not to bind for E and
we could see by mass structures the raw
data here's the process data that when
we mix these three components we see
April for e we see ribavirin 40
complexes and we don't see any of the
nonspecific complex strongly suggesting
at least here in vitro under these
conditions that we are forming specific
redditor and 40 complexes we also
extended these studies I'll go a bit
more quickly through this because most
of the section is is published but why
because 4e binds the tap intercalating
between 22 trip to fatten to tryptophan
residues in terms of making sort of an
aromatic sandwich this causes quenching
fluorescence quenching and nephew have
an entry to monitor intrinsic
fluorescence of the function of tap or
in this case ribavirin binding and use
that to monitor kds using standard
fluorescence techniques now ribavirin
active metabolites in the cells
ribavirin triphosphate RTP so you're
seeing data for both ribavirin and
ribavirin triphosphate here we can see
that some n7 gtp-binding and are cheap
ebooks are cheaper binding curves are
very similar getting very similar kds we
expect this out RTP because of the
addition of the phosphates is already
published for GDP increases affinity
quite substantially over just survival
grand by itself we also note that
mutation of the cat findings right here
Reds substantially impaired binding
whereas binding with 73 a shown here
doesn't substantially change the the
binding conscience
73a vs. wild type arrived in suggesting
that it's using is cat binding site for
binding this is this data i should say
was all done by alex tenses and the
future show nation raw data of what you
might expect to see our fee is here in
reds and forty orgy or for apush GTP is
in green and blue and so here in the raw
data here by even feel the fear [ __ ]
there we only see clenching by our GP
but not GTP this is mouse Corey this is
human 4e there are only four residues
different so we often use them
interchangeably so next bit of evidence
that I'll show you here is done by Alex
tennis is Eugene cap chromatography and
here we have the tap attach to a solid
support we run forward through and
attaches device to the cap is conceived
by western blot and then we can add a
tap or RTP and see that we have very
similar profiles of inhibition of
binding as we increase a similar
experiment done by on Papa fear of it
shows that if we have for a bound here
to the cap column Archie pm-7 GDP and m7
GP PG which are two different forms of
the cat all three of these cause
Aleutian from the from the beads whereas
GTP and GP g do not again suggesting a
specific interaction of ribavirin and
the cap but not our negative controls
and this is just some seedy data where
we can show that addition of m7 gtp and
RTP cause changes in the secondary
structure of pori upon binding whereas
gtp does not end these changes seem to
be similar and overall an overall extent
causing minor changes which is
consistent previous studies already
shown that the cap addition does not
cause global changes to the forage
structure this is new and mr data that
we have a complex of for e+ RTP where
you can see that in red is the addition
of RTP and in black is a PO and you're
just looking at an NMR spectra overlay
for those of you who are not familiar
with that mr each one of these peeps
represents the NH a my proton of each
amino acid or in some cases the indels
of the trip defense and the most
important point here is that where red
doesn't equal black means that the
addition of RTP is caused respectful
change and what we noticed here are
evidences by NMR of slow to intermediate
exchange which means that we have
finding in the load of sub micromolar kg
range consistent with the fluorescence
data that I've already presented above
so here's what some of the highlight
peaks of here in particular this looks
like f 48 which is in the CAF binding
pocket it was quite dramatically upon
binding and as you can see in some of
these other cases we just the loss of
signal which is a form of intermediate
exchange again indicating sub micromolar
micromolar binding constants
and if we map the chemical the NMR
changes that we observe onto the forage
structure and some of these changes are
just highlighted here we can see several
interesting features and now let me just
take you through this diagram for a
moment it's rather complicated but what
you have here is anything that colored
green means that because the spectra
overlap I don't actually know if it's
changed or not anything that cyan here
on the dorsal surface is mainly cyan
means that from our announcers we can
tell there was no change in that region
and most importantly what we can see
here is substantial changes in the beta
sheets and a cat binding site shown in
blue white side of blue white and yellow
that indicates that that the RTP is
causing changes in the animal cages in
the structure of 4e in and around the
cat fighting site consistent with our
previous mutational data and our end the
model that we've proposed of course
biophysics is lovely but ultimately we
would like to get we like to be sure
that rather than is actually binding for
Ian fells in terms of understanding this
is an inhibitor and moving forward so
what we've done in this particular
immunoprecipitation experiment is a
cross-linked IP where a treat cells of
treaty ated ribavirin and either with
ammunition state with for Eeyore IgG and
then assess what is the relative
enrichment and you can see here in these
experiments we have about a 13-fold
enrichment of the Association of
ribavirin with with endogenous 4e
relative to igg and what you're seeing
here are simply just the washes of the
bead so you know that we're not having
any left over radio activity that this
is a real enriching
now ok we have bought chemistry and we
can show it buys now does it do anything
so here you can see that ribavirin and
peas are any export activity of 40 we
took an RNA export target here cyclin d1
and you can see it's substantially
reduced and I should save it and in a
paper by then even show from sonnenberg
loud and the nineteen ninety six or so
in pnas had demonstrated that cyclin d1
was an export but not a translation
target Ofori and that's why we chose to
monitor here what you can also see is
that that if we look at RNA export here
we're looking at nuclear nuclear
retention is a function of ribavirin
addition a game fractionating cells and
using real-time pcr to monitor the
transcripts that we we have in a
substantial enrichment of second view
and transcripts in the nucleus as a
function of ribavirin concentration the
veg acts which is a translation but not
an export target of 4e is not changed at
the export level and total rnas are
unchanged furthermore if we take an
analog which is actually in the
fluorescence spectrum of sweats and
slide I showed you forgot to mention of
ribavirin ribavirin called brute force
feed which for some structural reasons
doesn't find 4e we can see it has no
effect on on cyclin d1 level so this is
another evidence of specificity
what we see here isn't as possible
analysis and so what we're looking at is
the amount of any given transcripts
loaded onto the room onto the ribosome
so if we have this is looking at real
time pcr cycles and so the lower number
correlates to having more RNA present
now first we can just look here at SAP
th and what I am sorry I should also say
that these are paison fractions and so
you're more efficiently translated in
the higher polynomial fractions than say
in the ribosome or monotone fractions so
here is and that this work I should also
say we've done by evanka berkovich and
what you can what you can see here is
that gap th for instance has its apply
them unchanged by the addition of
ribavirin and again this is consistent
with work that was published in the new
show at all nineteen ninety 16s paper
that i mentioned earlier where Jack th
the puzzle in of death eh was shown
should not be changed by five for
overexpression so this is consistent
this is not a sensitive RNA the black
here is showing you just the overall
poly verbal profile and so rather grand
is not having a gross effect on the
polynomial profile but what we can see
for some transcripts that are
translation sensitive and remember OTC
is one of these special ones its
translation and an export sensitive but
here at translation you can see that the
addition of ribavirin causes a reduction
in the amount of RNA that's in the
polyfoam fraction relative to the amount
that's in lower efficiency translating
fractions and similarly you can see this
for veg f and purple cyclin d1 was an
ironing export but not a translation
fraction and what you can see yvonne's
data shows here is that we don't have we
don't have a change in the polynomial
distribution these are just simply
translations of this because before
ribavirin we have much more seconds e1
RNA in the site
and after I the fair but if pies on the
loading is unchanged and so this shows
you that right of aaron has the same of
the sort of that same converse effects
of 4e that you would expect a before e
inhibitor and inhibits both the export
and translation functions consistent the
model of being a competitor that we've
already shown finally this is an
interesting piece of data from Philippa
pearson from wilson Miller's labs that
which was published last year we're
using a breast cancer cell lines she can
actually show that if you do SI for if
you do fi for e plus ribavirin you don't
have any additional effects versus
versus SI alone strongly suggesting that
both things are inhibiting the same
pathway in a game suggesting specificity
in terms of ribavirin suppressing this
this particular functionality of four E
and that for years of I deterrent target
if we go on and look at full-size
formation assays you can see that by the
variance substantially suppresses cells
transformed with 4e this is just simply
the quantification of this and our
analog rib for see that didn't change
cyclin d1 also does not change the
number of fish I finally if we look at
next to find me if we look at an animal
model of cells that are known to be for
a dependent from previous studies from
the DIA vendetti lab body styles at the
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
cell line in a xenograft model you can
see quite quite strikingly the my stick
god about no return they simply got PBS
versus of ice that got right over and
that there's a substantial difference in
tumor load in
Intergraph suggesting that in vivo this
could work rather very non we then
tested its ability to inhibit colony
formation in primary human m4 and m5 AML
cells so here we're looking at the
number of both I relative to untreated
controls for either normal bone marrow
and m5 AML or terrain m5 AML or an m1a
ml or an m5 AML so what we can see is
that and i should say this is a log
scale so m1e and I'll does not have eyes
for you and we see it's got about the
same sensitivity is normal bone marrow
and quite a difference in terms of ic50
giving us sort of a therapeutic window
to be able to specifically target those
AML that have high for e I'm only
showing you three specimens here but we
published extensively so you know many
many colony growth assays using the sort
of set up and probably analyzed with
gained over 100 specimens so you're
seeing a representation of a big data
pool so Anna why are we focused on amo
and poor prognosis AML is obviously the
overall survival tends to be at five
years less than ten percent and really
it's a very aggressive disease huge and
we need really need new therapies
because the standard of care therapies
that being the same since the 1970s and
haven't really been working that well so
if we look at this paper by Alan
brunette we can see that AML four
patients particularly over 60 where the
majority of patients will be diagnosed
with AML that the overall survival
curves look pretty bleak as I said
average onset is in the late 60s many of
these patients cannot actually survive
can't receive intensive chemo
therapy patients do not receive
intensive chemotherapy have an overall
survival about four months and with
intensive chemotherapy there's a
substantial forty to sixty five percent
complete remission rate which is great
but there's an eighty-five percent will
relapse and patients clearly need
consolidation or their CR duration will
be very short just two to four months
and as I said overall survival at five
years is less than ten percent so here's
a bit more about AML as I as I said
there's no new standard of care since
the 1970s and this is being based on air
FC plus an actor cycling and is known in
the field and seven plus three just to
let you know the current management of
AML and older adults there is no is
unsatisfactory a standard of care yet to
emerge and the National Comprehensive
Cancer Network which is the network that
cents what coughs chemotherapy should be
used in each kind of capture guidelines
recommend the clinical trials as the
first option for nearly all patients
with AML over the age of 60 this is
taken from coming a booth review and
unique problems with AML include unlike
other malignancies that life expectancy
of older patients with AML who opted for
palliative care alone may be measured in
days not weeks or months so I just want
to give you a setting so you understand
what's a good result and what the bad
result because clearly although we'd
like to cure everyone that and that as a
first step is probably too much to ask
so we used m4 and m5 AML patients
because we knew that they had high 4e
and we knew that their primary
specimens were sensitive to right over
so we carried out first to proof of
principle phase 2 clinical trial using
ribavirin monotherapy no other therapies
were permitted during this treatment the
patients that we have are typical of a
clinical trial there either refractory
and that they never responded to the
therapy or they relapse ie they
initially responded and then the cancer
came back and in m45 AML patients
because ma ml m4 m5 subgroups in
particular make this a small patient
population particularly in Canada of we
were a multicenter clinical trial which
was run out of the Jewish General
Hospital with Wilson Miller's Clinical
Research Unit and sherry a saline being
the key medical monitor and sufficient
in charge of the trial we also had
patients from opt I'll make enough
rosemont here unless y'all I should they
Jewish general hospitals in the gill
hospital here in Montreal and out of
Hamilton Ontario to McMaster Cancer
Center with Brian Lieber and we also
have a website if anyone is interested
for for our total patients of we had
fifteen evaluable patients that means
patients that were on trial for at least
15 days 12 of them showed some kind
clinical improvement we had a complete
remission which we had totally
unanticipated in fact when we started
the trial the doctor athlean had
suggested to me that the probably ish
just preparing myself for stark failure
and that no one will respond and
particularly in this very very hard
refractory relapse setting so to have a
complete and to partial or omissions was
really way more than we hoped for we
also have three blasts responses and
that's a fifty percent or more reduction
in blasts which I leukemia cancer cells
so that those patients also had a
response we have six stable diseases
which means that the patients didn't get
worse and actually in AML that
considered a response and three
progressive diseases ie these patients
absolutely did not respond in one of
these partial remission patients we
actually had a condition called a
leukemia cutis where these patients had
skin lesions which isn't for the
metastatic as you will form of leukemia
and here we could see a regression of
skin lesions in indicating that we were
able to target remote disease which is
also optimistic the patients in the
trial were all we only had one patient
with favorable cytogenetics the rest of
the patients are intermediate to adverse
risk presided genetics and had
unfavorable molecular markers so this
was by no means a trial where we
selected favorable patients to do well
really the University we had the very
sort of worst-case scenarios this is
just to show you that in the patients we
see similar results to do what we see in
South now first of all here is a bone
marrow of the patient that was in
complete remission before treatment and
28 days after oral ribavirin were the
nice things about our child's that
patients could take a bottle full of
ribavirin pills home and not have to
stay in the hospital all the time and
you can also see that for instances
patients platelets were recovering over
time so that they were seeing normal
blood differentiation here in the
confocal microscope micrographs of 40
stained cells and green and blue is
nappy and what we can see here is that
40 is very clear very much like those
cells I showed you at the very beginning
of the presentation and what you can
probably see if you blow up your screen
is that four is now moved mainly to the
cytoplasm this was a molecular response
that we completely anticipated because
previous studies in cell culture showed
that rather grim treatment moved for it
to the cytoplasm is probably why it's
inhibiting Arnie export and similar
studies have been done by the Sandberg
lavage or fado say that showed that for
you moved the tap treatments move
forward to the cytoplasm
as well in terms of molecular response
we can see that our 40 targets such as
nbs1 and actually I didn't have time to
show you but for your for overexpression
leads to a KP activations or rather burn
treatment actually leads to decreased
apt activation so here our molecular
response is pretty much as we expected
we were quite surprised that in all
cases we also shop for e RNA or 40
protein and RNA levels go down and so
clearly this is a mixture of looking at
rather than inhibition and reduction in
4e we typically do not see four levels
be reduced until around day 15 however
very early on we can see 40 move so
somewhere between i should say for he
moves by day 15 RNA levels down by cycle
one or day 28 indicating that the
initial response is probably for you
moving out and then some sort of
adaptive response in these cells or a
specific selection of a subpopulation of
cells now lower 40 is occurring in the
right either untreated patients
consistent with vision impairment of
ribavirin we can see that the RNA export
function in particular for this is a
patient 10 for EDS one RNA that's true
for other patients and other rnase is
substantially reduced by 28 days and in
this particular patient that correlated
with patient achieving a complete affray
of last response and i should say that
of the patients that didn't respond they
had no molecular response and we believe
that they have to have impairment of
uptake of ribavirin this is another
another patient who achieved the blast
response here you can see red are the
are the bone marrow the percent of cells
that are tumors or leukemic glasses bone
marrow and in blue is from peripheral
blood and what we can see is when the
patients doing well we see the for you
moving out and actually you see this in
many patients that as as the blast
counts go up we see reentry afore ye
we're very keen but don't yet understand
completely what what modulates the the
import and export of queries on the
nucleus but clearly this is quite keen
to understanding what's going on I
should say that this in this case in
most of the cases that we monitored we
did not see for a levels themselves
elevate upon resistance so what next
well clearly we want to understand the
molecular underpinnings of resistance
but I don't have time to talk to you
about that today but we have just last
slide or two to show you that some that
we can combine ribavirin with low-dose
therapy which is although a chemotherapy
one that many elderly patients can
tolerate well and see if this can
increase the frequency and duration of
responses so in this trial design and
the phase one portion of this trial is
ongoing we can see that we do have quite
dramatic responses this is just the sort
of scheduling of drugs but we see that
response rate responsive patients that
achieve 20 micro molar and more
ribavirin in this trial are quite
dramatic and had to complete remissions
when they lasted for two years and one
for nine months we had a partial
remission where the patient had to be
taken off not because of leukemia but
because of the dose-limiting toxicity we
had a blast response patient that was
six months plus and another blasters
mugs for months bus and stable disease
and many patients that did not respond
now we did run into some TK issues I
don't have time to talk about today but
what you can see is that the patients
that achieved less than 20 micro molar
vie de Gran and i should say there's no
toxicity associated with this level of
ribavirin at all we didn't tend to have
such nice dramatic results and the only
side effect you've only seen in a
handful of patients i should say it out
of the shortest 40 patients we treated
for the two trials is is hemolytic
anemia which is completely reversible
and obviously much less toxic than your
standard
chemotherapies this is just to show you
that we have a similar pattern of
molecular response this is the patient
that responded for 42 years clearly i'm
only showing an early window of her
response these are the percent of bone
marrow leukemia cell she has so clearly
nicely going down and what we can see is
as are going down we're seeing before
you move out and stay out and
unfortunately when she relapse 22 years
we saw for you re-enter the cell as
we've seen previously so just to to wind
up I hope hopefully now that you think
the eif4e is is a protein asst we're
targeting and we're thinking about that
for a modulation nuclear pore complex
and promote our new export
transformation and this is important or
not only from cell biological
perspective of coming up with a new
function for the nuclear pore and
oncogenic transformation but also
showing you that this is relevant to to
patients who have just regulated are any
export hope you've also showing you the
targeting for interface to monotherapy
trial with ribavirin show submission and
we have some reason for hope we still
have some challenges to overcome in our
combination setting and we have many
many challenges and put some hope and
future for understanding what why
patients eventually become resistance
and this is unfortunately talk if I
didn't have time to talk about today but
we do have a pretty good handle on that
and I just like to end by thanking the
many people that were involved
particularly our clinical colleagues
three a queen Wilson Miller Brian labor
Julie Bergeron and any code law being
central to the clinical trial efforts my
collaborator Craig Jordans been central
fur for aiding us in a primary AML
studies early on Billy has chiquilla
Kovich track glitch and orally bi gay
did most of the nuclear pore complex of
data that I showed you Alex tenses and
my retina on Toppa fear which were key
in the early Rio Grande experiments
laron Volpone and Mike Osbourne have
done done with the more recent NMR
arrive Eric
I particularly like to thank the
patients and their families for being
willing to try our child and for the
funding agencies for helping obviously
for making all of this work possible and
I'd like to thank you for your attention
so i guess i will try to work out now
how to go to the questions and answers
and questions sections oh and i would
also like to say that that there's a
that there's a chat room that i'll go to
shortly after this this talk but i
probably only stay about 10 minutes if
if nobody comes and if nobody has any
questions now I probably only stay here
on the question and answer session for
for a minute or two and so right now
there there there doesn't seem to be any
questions let's let me see make sure I
get this all my questions Thank You
Darlene for thanking me for presentation
it makes you know somebody is listening
in the setting is very hard to know if
there's any impact and I don't know if
there's anything else I can tell you of
use I just remind you to go to those
website the conference live website to
get your siiii credits if that was
something that you were after today and
there's
okay so thanks then cross promote
inviting me for a game is talking for
your questions so Vincent's question is
any thoughts on the implications of your
work on nuclear translation or nmd and
clearly it's a great question we've
thought about it a lot so with with our
studies since W 73a is a mutant that
axwell in export and oncogenic
transformation and changing the nuclear
pore as I showed you but our studies and
other studies have also shown it doesn't
act in translation because it doesn't
find 4G very well because of the
mutation on the dorsal surface and so
I'm guessing that if there could be the
clear translations don't get me wrong
but I'm guessing what we're looking at
is probably not directly related to to
nuclear translation because of this
mutation and maybe that is more CBC
related in the nucleus the other major
cap binding protein so that's that's all
I I can say for that thanks I owe me for
liking the presentation so I'm just
trying to think if there was any other
worthwhile thing to tell you only way to
see if there's any other questions
okay okay here's a question from
Jonathan moat liar dr. Paulson and dr.
problem from Penn State discovered that
a derivative of fish oil has a very
strong effect against leukemia have I
collaborated with them know that sounds
like a fascinating finding but but which
I certainly need to go back and read
about because I I don't think I was
aware of so no I I haven't collaborated
with them but that sounds like a cool
idea
so I guess I'll just stay maybe for
another minute or so and if anybody have
any burning questions we can go to the
to the chat room
so I think the chat room opens at eleven
if it opens earlier i'll obviously go
earlier otherwise i'll be there from
like 11 to 11 10 unless there's already
lots of people there and lots of
questions to ask so thanks very much for
wherever you're listening from 2 to be
listening and I guess that's that's the
it for for me thank you again
Oh
also there's one last question Jonathan
monk Meyer apps will be available for
viewing your game later and yes I've
been told by the organizers absolutely
it will be and if you have any questions
and you can't make the chat room I
should have put my email on the screen
but please feel free to email me at
Catherine got bored and at you Montreal
CA and and you can tell me more about
fish oil to Jean ok
you